[Music]
the arrowverse has become a complex web
of timelines tv shows and crossover
events
barry allen star of the flash is a
wonderful entry point into the shared
universe having started on arrow and
become a headlining hero in his own
right
this is his story from beginning to end
by all accounts barry allen had an ideal
childhood
his memories of it are filled with
watching old musicals with his mother
nora and traveling to museums with his
father henry
that would all change on march 18 2000
when noor was killed by an inexplicable
phenomenon
barry startled by a commotion downstairs
discovered his mother surrounded by
strange streaks of red and yellow
lightning
he briefly made out a man in yellow
tearing through the room at impossible
speeds
when his father told him to run barry
took off and suddenly found himself
several blocks away by the time barry
made it back to his home his father was
being dragged away in handcuffs and his
mother was dead
barry went to live with the family of
his closest friend where his budding
interest
in science became a full-blown obsession
though he couldn't prove his father was
innocent on his own
he knew there had to be a way to
exonerate him with concrete evidence
he dedicated the rest of his schooling
to studying physics chemistry and
criminology
barry inhabits the aeroverse the cw's
live-action superhero canon
this shared universe began with arrow a
2012 series centered around oliver queen
aka green arrow
barry's beginning in the arrowverse
arrives in the second season aero
episode the scientist
who the hell are you and do your parents
know that you're here i'm barry allen
by this point in his life barry allen
has become a criminologist
still deeply troubled by his mother's
death he travels to star city
in the hopes of meeting his idol green
arrow he lies his way onto his team
pretending to be working on a case on
behalf of central city's police
department
while there he impresses green arrow by
correctly figuring out
a lot of information about the way the
masked vigilante operates
barry's story eventually falls apart
however forcing him to reveal that he's
looking to work on supernatural
cases if he can prove a case to be the
work of things beyond our current
comprehension he believes he'll be able
to exonerate his father
and solve his mother's murder after
solving a cold case and saving green
arrow's life allen hops a train back to
central city
after his adventures on arrow barry
allen's stand-alone story truly begins
on that train back to central city he
meets fellow physicist martin stein
and the two quickly bond over their
shared interest in a particle
accelerator project
being run out of star labs they say it's
going to change the world
i hope so even as barry carries on his
work as a crime scene investigator he
can't shake the idea of the work being
done by star
barry's fixation is understandable the
particle accelerator promises to reveal
undiscovered realms of science since he
has dedicated his life to solving the
mystery of his mother's death
any grand expansion of scientific
understanding is of interest to barry
he didn't need to be enamored with the
accelerator for what came next however
the massive machine explodes sending a
shock wave across the city
barry is struck by lightning through a
nearby window and falls into a coma
when he is hospitalized the staff notice
all sorts of strange phenomena including
a constant flat lining that has no ill
effect upon him
the mind behind star labs accelerator dr
harrison wells
realizes that barry's heart is beating
too fast to register on hospital
equipment
when it becomes clear that they are
dealing with something entirely out of
the ordinary a comatose berry is moved
to star for closer observation
barry wakes after nine comatose months
and quickly discovers that something is
wrong with him
he heals from injuries rapidly and
begins experiencing time dilation
moments slow down as his perception
heightens to impossible speed
he runs realizes that he's been given
the gift of super speed and sets about
testing the limits of his new powers
in the course of figuring out what's
going on with him barry realizes that
he's not alone in possessing superpowers
in the wake of the accelerators
explosion all sorts of central city
criminals have developed extraordinary
abilities
barry comes to grips with his powers and
begins to solve crimes
and foil villains in central city as the
flash
as he uncovers more and more about the
fallout of the explosion he begins to
suspect that dr harrison wells
is not who he seems i don't know how
but he's the man in yellow harrison
wells is the reverse flash
everything comes to a head when barry's
adoptive father joe west and his star
labs associate cisco ramon uncover
harrison wells body
barry's crew heads to the lab and
discover harrison wells to be a false
persona
this is impossible caitlyn
i ran the dna test twice it's a perfect
match
they uncover a secret room containing
the yellow costume of the man barry saw
the night his mother died as well
as a news clipping from 2024 the team
works out that wells is someone from the
future
eobard thawne a villain known as reverse
flash who regularly battles the flash in
his own time
he goes back to barry's timeline to kill
him as a child
but is thwarted by a future version of
the flash and ends up stuck in the past
he took on well's identity to guide the
lab toward making the particle
accelerator
the explosion was an intentional event
to create the flash so that he might
harness barry's abilities to return to
his own time
after several fights between eobard and
barry police detective eddie thawne
realizes that he can stop eobard from
ever existing
since eobard is a direct descendant of
eddie eddie knows that killing himself
would cause eobard to wink out of
existence
eddie shoots himself with his service
pistol and eovar disappears
i've controlled your life for so long
how will you get along without me
the second season of the flash gives
barry a new nemesis
like eobard he disguises himself as a
friend despite
actually being from another time and
place he is hunter zolomon
and he has traveled to barry's dimension
through a rift created by eobard's
disappearance
solomon comes from another earth where
he is a serial killer obsessed with
making himself fast
he has traveled to barry's earth in
order to harvest his speed energy he
disguises himself as jay garrick
a flash from yet another timeline and
befriends barry
all the while he acts as the villainous
zoom giving barry a reason to hone his
powers
a process jay helps with naturally
solomon manages to call
forth a time remnant of himself so that
barry can see it die
believing that his mentor has been
killed barry trains all the harder
eventually the star labs team learns of
zolomon's true identity
leading to a showdown between zoom and
the flash
he kills flash's father henry and
attempts to destroy the entire
multiverse but
barry outsmarts him using the same time
remnant trick zoom used on him
time rates pull zoom out of the universe
and trap him within the speed force
barry's entire life has been driven up
to this point by the dream of obtaining
justice for his father
with his dad suddenly dead barry is
completely unmoored
he simply cannot tolerate any further
suffering he has lived his life in
pursuit of one goal
righting the wrong that has kept his
living parent separated from him and
that goal has been snatched away
i feel more broken than i've ever felt
in my life
in spite of all he's learned about
timeline meddling being dangerous barry
runs back to the night his mother died
and saves her life
he then beats reverse flash unconscious
and uses a dampening cage to trap him in
a prison in 2016.
in this newly altered timeline barry
begins to lose the memories of his
former life
surprisingly barry is still an
investigator living a happy life with
his family fully intact pursuing a
relationship with his childhood friend
iris
despite the seeming peace of this
reality all is not well
barry's treks around central city make
him realize that his friends are
suffering
iris younger brother wally west becomes
the flash in barry's absence but with
nowhere near the same level of support
without the backing of a team like star
labs wally runs himself ragged fighting
a villain called the rival
barry agrees to help wally where he can
but eventually sees that it is no use
after wally is seriously hurt while
fighting barry is faced with a terrible
choice
he can reset the timeline by freeing
reverse flash to kill his mother or he
can allow his friends to continue
suffering in the new world he has
wrought
barry makes the choice you'd expect of a
hero taking reverse flash back to the
past
he accepts that injustice to prevent a
greater one once the timeline is
restored however not everything is back
to where it once belonged
relationships have changed and fragments
from flashpoint begin to find their way
into barry's world
season 3 of the flash had perhaps the
most confusing villain in the history of
the series
savitar was a time remnant a sort of
speedster superglue that works to stick
together the space-time continuum
whenever a speedforce user smashes it to
bits with all their time travel
savitar exists in a paradoxical time
loop essentially by killing iris savitar
sets into motion the creation of the
time remnant that will eventually
become savitar and i only need two more
things
[Music]
for iris to die so that you are driven
so far into the dark that i can be born
in order to save his future wife barry
and his friends enlist the help of earth
3's flash
jay garrick to defeat savitar once and
for all
barry and iris finally take their
marriage vows during the fourth season
of the flash
but the ceremony actually starts in a
season 3 supergirl episode
friends of the bride and groom are at
the proceedings when it's interrupted by
an assault from the villains of earth x
in alternate earth where the axis powers
won world war ii
and subsequently conquered the globe the
attack heralds the fourth of the
arrowverse's annual crossover events
crisis on earth x the leaders of the new
reichsman
include evil counterparts to the
arrowverse heroes like dark arrow oliver
queen and his wife
overgirl earth x's answer to supergirl
barry and
many of the other aeroverse heroes are
captured and placed in earth x's
concentration camps
with the help of the earth x heroes from
the freedom fighters barry and the other
heroes are rescued
tragically martin stein is mortally
wounded while trying to open a portal
back to earth 1 and
later dies after the heroes drive back
the earth x assault the wedding of barry
and iris is finally made official
the flash's fourth season introduces a
slew of new baddies all created by a
single mastermind
when barry confronts this head honcho he
finds a dying man in a wheelchair
named clifford devoe he underestimates
the man and barry is framed for his
murder
devoe transfers his consciousness into
the body of one of the meta-humans he
created
while in prison barry and a number of
other metahumans nearly get sold to a
black market dealer and superpowers
named amunet black
berry is eventually able to clear his
name and davao continues to hop around
the bodies of those he created
the flash and his friend set about
warning his remaining progeny
devoe reveals his plan he hopes to use a
series of satellites to permanently
rewire
every human on earth a plot he calls the
enlightenment
barry teams up with amunet black and
they destroyed devoe's main satellite
with the bomb procured via their
connection to illegal markets
davao had planned for that eventuality
however he takes over the satellite
system at star labs
and initiates the enlightenment the
flash very nearly fails to stop davao
but a new speed force user named nora
appears and helps to stop the
destruction
but nora comes bearing bad news i think
i made a big
big mistake nora tells barry and iris
that she
is their daughter from the future she
came back in time to stop a new villain
named cicada who is an unstoppable force
in her own timeline
it is revealed throughout the season as
barry and his allies attempt to mitigate
the havoc being reeked on the timeline
that nora is regularly traveling back
into the future to work with the
villainous eobard thawne
the bad guy it seems has earned nora's
trust while imprisoned and he's
manipulated her into traveling to the
past to set in motion events that might
set him free
a magical dagger that holds thon captive
in a prison of the future is destroyed
in the past allowing him to break out of
prison and reappear in the main timeline
the timeline shifting ends in nora
winking out of existence leaving barry
and iris without a daughter
a lot of dc lore has come to the screen
over the last few decades but until
season six of the flash no one had
attempted to take on crisis on infinite
earths
as a villain known as the anti-monitor
threatened to wipe out all
existence on the page the landmark
crossover comics event gave dc a clean
slate by wiping out the myriad parallel
universes that had appeared to account
for decades of continuity problems
in creating a single unified dc universe
countless iterations of famous
characters were killed
in the comics this included barry allen
who sacrificed himself in a move that
allowed other heroes to defeat the
anti-monitor
television's aeroverse saw a similarly
cataclysmic restart in season six of the
flash
and viewers who only knew barry through
grant gustin's portrayal finally came to
understand the terms pre-crisis and
post-crisis
season six of the flash begins with
barry learning that the crisis is coming
sooner than team flash had hoped
december 10 2019
[Music]
on that day he will answer the call
and make the ultimate sacrifice it
becomes clear that the flash will die
during the multiverse wide shake-up and
barry begins preparing all of his
friends family and fellow crime fighters
for a world without him
at the same time a villain called
bloodwork threatens central city
blood work is attempting to find a cure
for a deadly disease that runs in his
family but the treatment he found
turned him monstrous and filled him with
the need for the blood of others to
maintain an eternal life
at some point he realizes that his blood
can effectively control others if it
gets into their system and he sets out
to create an
army of blood brothers bloodwork's quest
for never ending life and barry
accepting his fate are played as mirrors
of each other throughout the season
even as alan is infected and controlled
by the villain bloodwork's master plan
to infect the entire city ultimately
backfires
and all of his minions are returned to
normal in their confrontation with the
anti-monitor
another flash named barry allen from a
different part of the multiverse ends up
sacrificing himself to save existence
barry allen does die it turns out just
not the one who leads the flash
sorry kid but this has to happen
the season closes with barry attempting
to carry on in a newly created
multiverse that only he and a few other
metahumans know is not the world as it
was
his actions during the crisis also
destroy the speed force
the borderline mystical reserve of
energy from which speedsters pulled
their powers
after the events of crisis on infinite
earths barry and wally learn the speed
force is in trouble
confronting the speed force's human
manifestation barry learns that when
oliver queen used his specter powers to
get barry back into the speed force
during crisis
it contaminated things the speed force
seemingly dies
leaving barry and wally only weeks of
residual speedster powers
with the help of nora west allen's diary
team flash builds an artificial speed
force that barry can access but once
again
the cost is too high even though nash
wells sacrifices himself to power the
asf with his multiversal energy
team flash learns the asf is causing
barry's thinking to go as fast as his
body with catastrophic consequences to
his personality
once barry realizes what's happening to
him he disables the new source of his
powers
but with the help of the re-emerged
harrison wells the residual speed force
within iris and the asf
team flash later succeeds in essentially
rebooting the speed force giving barry
back his powers
on the night of the star labs particle
accelerator explosion
eva mcculloch is killed as she's thrown
into a mirror
the dark matter creates a mirror
universe duplicate of eva
with all of her memories stuck in the
mirror verse a universe governed by
different physical laws
the new mirror eva tricks iris into
allowing herself to be pulled into the
mirror verse
while a mere duplicate of iris replaces
her on earth prime
after also capturing and creating
duplicates of singh and cisco's
girlfriend camilla
even now calling herself mirror monarch
finally escapes to earth prime
mirror monarch plans to take over the
globe by replacing everyone with mirror
counterparts and barry is distracted
dealing with the death of the speed
force
once it's restored barry and iris are
able to stop mirror monarch's plans and
make her see the error of her ways
she returns earth prime's people and
retreats to the mirror verse
but it's clear that mere monarch has
left a dark scar on central city
irish joins a support group founded
specifically to help those who are
abducted and traumatized by the villain
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite arrowverse heroes are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]